PETER SZOLOVITS: All right.
Let's get started.
Good afternoon.
So last time, I started
talking about the use
of natural language processing
to process clinical data.
And things went a
little bit slowly.
And so we didn't get through
a lot of the material.
I'm going to try to
rush a bit more today.
And as a result, I have
a lot of stuff to cover.
So if you remember,
last time, I started
by saying that a
lot of the NLP work
involves coming up with
phrases that one might
be interested in to help
identify the kinds of data
that you want, and then just
looking for those in text.
So that's a very simple method.
But it's one that
works reasonably well.
And then Kat Liao was
here to talk about some
of the applications
of that kind of work
in what she's been doing
in cohort selection.
So what I want to
talk about today
is more sophisticated
versions of that,
and then move on to more
contemporary approaches
to natural language processing.
So this is a paper
that was given
to you as one of the
optional readings last time.
And it's work from
David Sontag's lab,
where they said, well, how do
we make this more sophisticated?
So they start the same way.
They say, OK, Dr.
Liao, let's say,
give me terms that are very
good indicators that I have
the right kind of
patient, if I find them
in the patient's notes.
So these are things with
high predictive value.
So you don't want to use a term
like sick, because that's going
to find way too many people.
But you want to
find something that
is very specific but that
has a high predictive value
that you are going to
find the right person.
And then what they
did is they built
a model that tries to
predict the presence
of that word in the
text from everything
else in the medical record.
So now, this is an example of a
silver-standard way of training
a model that says, well, I don't
have the energy or the time
to get doctors to
look through thousands
and thousands of records.
But if I select these
anchors well enough,
then I'm going to get a high
yield of correct responses
from those.
And then I train
a machine learning
model that learns to
identify those same terms,
or those same records that
have those terms in them.
And by the way, from
that, we're going
to learn a whole
bunch of other terms
that are proxies for the
ones that we started with.
So this is a way of
enlarging that set of terms
automatically.
And so there are a bunch
of technical details
that you can find out
about by reading the paper.
They used a relatively
simple representation,
which is essentially a
bag-of-words representation.
They then sort of
masked the three words
around the word that
actually is the one they're
trying to predict
just to get rid
of short-term
syntactic correlations.
And then they built an
L2-regularized logistic
regression model that said, what
are the features that predict
the occurrence of this word?
And then they expanded
the search vocabulary
to include those
features as well.
And again, there
are tons of details
about how to discretize
continuous values
and things like that that
you can find out about.
So you build a
phenotype estimator
from the anchors and
the chosen predictors.
They calculated a
calibration score
for each of these
other predictors that
told you how well it predicted.
And then you can build
a joint estimator
that uses all of these.
And the bottom line is
that they did very well.
So in order to
evaluate this, they
looked at eight different
phenotypes for which
they had human judgment data.
And so this tells
you that they're
getting AUCs of
between 0.83 and 0.95
for these different phenotypes.
So that's quite good.
They, in fact, were estimating
not only these eight phenotypes
but 40-something.
I don't remember the exact
number, much larger number.
But they didn't
have validated data
against which to
test the others.
But the expectation is that
if it does well on these,
it probably does well
on the others as well.
So this was a very nice idea.
And just to illustrate, if
you start with something
like diabetes as a
phenotype and you say,
well, I'm going to
look for anchors
that are a code of
250 diabetes mellitus,
or I'm going to
look at medication
history for diabetic therapy--
so those are the silver-standard
goals that I'm looking at.
And those, in fact, have a high
predictive value for somebody
being in the cohort.
And then they identify
all these other features
that predict those,
and therefore, in turn,
predict appropriate
selectors for the phenotype
that they're interested in.
And if you look at the
paper again, what you see
is that this
outperforms, over time,
the standard supervised baseline
that they're comparing against,
where you're getting much
higher accuracy early
in a patient's visit to
be able to identify them
as belonging to this cohort.
I'm going to come back later to
look at another similar attempt
to generalize from a core using
a different set of techniques.
So you should see that in
about 45 minutes, I hope.
Well, context is important.
So if you look at a sentence
like Mr. Huntington was treated
for Huntington's disease at
Huntington Hospital, located
on Huntington Avenue, each
of those mentions of the word
Huntington is different.
And for example, if you're
interested in eliminating
personally identifiable
health information
from a record like
this, then certainly you
want to get rid of the
Mr. Huntington part.
You don't want to get rid
of Huntington's disease,
because that's a
medically relevant fact.
And you probably do want to
get rid of Huntington Hospital
and its location on
Huntington Avenue,
although those are not
necessarily something
that you're prohibited
from retaining.
So for example, if you're
trying to do quality studies
among different
hospitals, then it
would make sense to retain the
name of the hospital, which
is not considered identifying
of the individual.
So we, in fact, did a study
back in the mid 2000s,
where we were trying to build
an improved de-identifier.
And here's the way
we went about it.
This is a kind of kitchen
sink approach that says,
OK, take the text, tokenize it.
Look at every single token.
And derive things from it.
So the words that
make up the token,
the part of speech,
how it's capitalized,
whether there's
punctuation around it,
which document
section is it in--
many databases have sort
of conventional document
structure.
If you've looked at the
mimic discharge summaries,
for example, there's a
kind of prototypical way
in which that flows
from beginning to end.
And you can use that
structural information.
We then identified a bunch of
patterns and thesaurus terms.
So we looked up, in the
UMLS, words and phrases
to see if they matched some
clinically meaningful term.
We had patterns that
identified things
like phone numbers and social
security numbers and addresses
and so on.
And then we did
parsing of the text.
So in those days,
we used something
called the Link
Grammar Parser, which,
doesn't make a whole lot
of difference what parser.
But you get either a constituent
or constituency or dependency
parse, which gives you
relationships among the words.
And so it allows you to
include, as features,
the way in which a word
that you're looking at
relates to other
words around it.
And so what we did is we
said, OK, the lexical context
includes all of the
above kind of information
for all of the words that
are either literally adjacent
or within n words of the
original word that you're
focusing on, or that are
linked by within k links
through the parse to that word.
So this gives you a very
large set of features.
And of course, parsing
is not a solved problem.
And so this is an
example from that story
that I showed you last time.
And if you see, it comes
up with 24 ambiguous parses
of this sentence.
So there are technical problems
about how to deal with that.
Today, you could use
a different parser.
The Stanford
Parser, for example,
probably does a better
job than the one
we were using 14 years
ago and gives you at least
more definitive answers.
And so you could
use that instead.
And so if you look
at what we did,
we said, well, here
is the text "Mr."
And here are all the ways that
you can look it up in the UMLS.
And it turns out to
be very ambiguous.
So M-R stands not
only for mister,
but it also stands for
Magnetic Resonance.
And it stands for a whole
bunch of other things.
And so you get huge
amounts of ambiguity.
"Blind" turns out also to
give you various ambiguities.
So it maps here to four
different concept-unique
identifiers.
"Is" is OK.
"79-year-old" is OK.
And then "male," again, maps to
five different concept-unique
identifiers.
So there are all these
problems of over-generation
from this database.
And here's some more, but
I'm going to skip over that.
And then the learning
model, in our case,
was a support vector machine for
this project, in which we just
said, well, throw in all the--
you know, it's
the kill them all,
and God will sort them
out kind of approach.
So we just threw in
all these features
and said, oh, support
vector machines
are really good at picking
out exactly what are the best
features.
And so we just relied on that.
And sure enough, so you wind
up with literally millions
of features.
But sure enough, it
worked pretty well.
And so Stat De-ID
was our program.
And you see that on real
discharge summaries,
we're getting precision
and recall on PHI
up around 98 and
1/2%, 95 and 1/4%,
which was much better than
the previous state of the art,
which had been based on
rules and dictionaries
as a way of
de-identifying things.
So this was a successful
example of that approach.
And of course, this is usable
not only for de-identification.
But it's also usable
for entity recognition.
Because instead of
selecting entities
that are personally
identifiable health information,
you could train it to select
entities that are diseases
or that are medications or
that are various other things.
And so this was, in the
2000s, a pretty typical way
for people to approach
these kinds of problems.
And it's still used today.
There are tools around
that let you do this.
And they work
reasonably effectively.
They're not state of
the art at the moment,
but they're simpler than
many of today's state
of the art methods.
So here's another approach.
This was something we published
a few years ago, where
we started working with
some psychiatrists and said,
could we predict
30-day readmission
for a psychiatric patient with
any degree of reliability?
That's a hard prediction.
Willie is currently
running an experiment
where we're asking
psychiatrists to predict that.
And it turns out, they're
barely better than chance
at that prediction.
So it's not an easy task.
And what we did is we said,
well, let's use topic modeling.
And so we had this
cohort of patients,
close to 5,000 patients.
About 10% of them
were readmitted
with a psych diagnosis.
And almost 3,000 of
them were readmitted
with other diagnoses.
So one thing this
tells you right away
is that if you're dealing
with psychiatric patients,
they come and go to the
hospital frequently.
And this is not good for the
hospital's bottom line because
of reimbursement policies of
insurance companies and so on.
So of the 4,700, only 1,240 were
not readmitted within 30 days.
So there's very
frequent bounce-back.
So we said, well, let's try
building a baseline model using
a support vector machine from
baseline clinical features
like age, gender,
public health insurance
as a proxy for
socioeconomic status.
So if you're on Medicaid,
you're probably poor.
And if you have
private insurance,
then you're probably an MIT
employee and/or better off.
So that's a frequently used
proxy, a comorbidity index
that tells you sort
of how sick you
are from things other than
your psychiatric problems.
And then we said,
well, what if we
add to that model
common words from notes.
So we said, let's do
a TF-IDF calculation.
So this is term frequency
divided by log of the document
frequency.
So it's sort of, how
specific is a term
to identify a particular
kind of condition?
And we take the 1,000 most
informative words, and so there
are a lot of these.
So if you use 1,000
most informative words
from these nearly
5,000 patients,
you wind up with something like
66,000 words, unique words,
that are informative
for some patient.
But if you limit
yourself to the top 10,
then it only uses 18,000 words.
And if you limit
yourself to the top one,
then it uses about 3,000 words.
And then we said, well, instead
of doing individual words,
let's do a latent
Dirichlet allocation.
So topic modeling on all of
the words, as a bag of words--
so no sequence information,
just the collection of words.
And so we calculated
75 topics from using
LDA on all these notes.
So just to remind
you, the LDA process
is a model that says
every document consists
of a certain mixture of topics,
and each of those topics
probabilistically
generates certain words.
And so you can build
a model like this,
and then solve it using
complicated techniques.
And you'd wind up with topics,
in this study, as follows.
I don't know.
Can you read these?
They may be too small.
So these are
unsupervised topics.
And if you look
at the first one,
it says patient, alcohol,
withdrawal, depression,
drinking, and Ativan,
ETOH, drinks, medications,
clinic inpatient, diagnosis,
days, hospital, substance,
use treatment program, name.
That's a de-identified
use/abuse problem number.
And we had our experts
look at these topics.
And they said, oh,
well, that topic
is related to alcohol abuse,
which seems reasonable.
And then you see, on
the bottom, psychosis,
thought features, paranoid
psychosis, paranoia symptoms,
psychiatric, et cetera.
And they said, OK,
that's a psychosis topic.
So in retrospect, you can
assign meaning to these topics.
But in fact, they're generated
without any a priori notion
of what they ought to be.
They're just a
statistical summarization
of the common co-occurrences
of words in these documents.
But what you find is that if you
use the baseline model, which
used just the demographic
and clinical variables,
and you say, what's the
difference in survival,
in this case, in
time to readmission
between one set and
another in this cohort,
and the answer is
they're pretty similar.
Whereas, if you use
a model that predicts
based on the baseline
and 75 topics,
the 75 topics that
we identified,
you get a much
bigger separation.
And of course, this is
statistically significant.
And it tells you
that this technique
is useful for being
able to improve
the prediction of
a cohort that's
more likely to be readmitted
from a cohort that's
less likely to be readmitted.
It's not a terrific prediction.
So the AUC for this model
was only on the order of 0.7.
So you know, it's not like 0.99.
But nevertheless, it
provides useful information.
The same group of psychiatrists
that we worked with also
did a study with a much larger
cohort but much less rich data.
So they got all
of the discharges
from two medical centers
over a period of 12 years.
So they had 845,000
discharges from 458,000
unique individuals.
And they were looking for
suicide or other causes
of death in these
patients to see
if they could predict
whether somebody
is likely to try
to harm themselves,
or whether they're likely
to die accidentally,
which sometimes can't be
distinguished from suicide.
So the censoring problems
that David talked about
are very much present in this.
Because you lose
track of people.
It's a highly
imbalanced data set.
Because out of the
845,000 patients, only 235
committed suicide, which is, of
course, probably a good thing
from a societal point
of view but makes
the data analysis hard.
On the other hand, all-cause
mortality was about 18%
during nine years
of a follow-up.
So that's not so imbalanced.
And then what they
did is they curated
a list of 3,000 terms
that correspond to what,
in the psychiatric literature,
is called positive valence.
So this is concepts like joy
and happiness and good stuff,
as opposed to negative valence,
like depression and sorrow
and all that stuff.
And they said, well, we can
use these types of terms
in order to help distinguish
among these patients.
And what they found is that, if
you plot the Kaplan-Meier curve
for different quartiles of
risk for these patients,
you see that there's a
pretty big difference
between the different quartiles.
And you can certainly
identify the people
who are more likely to commit
suicide from the people who
are less likely to do so.
This curve is for suicide
or accidental death.
So this is a much
larger data set,
and therefore the
error bars are smaller.
But you see the same
kind of separation here.
So these are all
useful techniques.
Now I'll to another approach.
This was work by one of
my students, Yuon Wo,
who was working with some
lymphoma pathologists
at Mass General.
And so the approach
they took was
to say, well, if you read a
pathology report about somebody
with lymphoma, can we
tell what type of lymphoma
they had from the
pathology report
if we blank out the part of
the pathology report that
says, "I, the pathologist, think
this person has non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma," or something?
So from the rest of the context,
can we make that prediction?
Now, Yuon took a kind of
interesting, slightly odd
approach to it,
which is to treat
this as an unsupervised
learning problem
rather than as a supervised
learning problem.
So he literally
masked the real answer
and said, if we just treat
everything except what
gives away the
answer as just data,
can we essentially cluster that
data in some interesting way
so that we re-identify the
different types of lymphoma?
Now, the reason this
turns out to be important
is because lymphoma
pathologists keep
arguing about how to
classify lymphomas.
And every few years, they
revise the classification rules.
And so part of his
objective was to say,
let's try to provide an
unbiased, data-driven method
that may help identify
appropriate characteristics
by which to classify
these different lymphomas.
So his approach was a tensor
factorization approach.
You often see data
sets like this
that's, say, patient
by a characteristic.
So in this case,
laboratory measurements--
so systolic/diastolic blood
pressure, sodium, potassium,
et cetera.
That's a very vanilla
matrix encoding of data.
And then if you add a
third dimension to it,
like this is at the
time of admission,
30 minutes later, 60 minutes
later, 90 minutes later,
now you have a
three-dimensional tensor.
And so just like you can
do matrix factorization, as
in the picture above, where
we say, my matrix of data,
I'm going to assume is generated
by a product of two matrices,
which are smaller in dimension.
And you can train
this by saying,
I want entries in
these two matrices
that minimize the
reconstruction error.
So if I multiply these
matrices together,
then I get back my
original matrix plus error.
And I want to
minimize that error,
usually root mean square, or
mean square error, or something
like that.
Well, you can play the
same game for a tensor
by having a so-called core
tensor, which identifies
the subset of characteristics
that subdivide
that dimension of your data.
And then what you
do is the same game.
You have matrices corresponding
to each of the dimensions.
And if you multiply
this core tensor
by each of these
matrices, you reconstruct
the original tensor.
And you can train it again to
minimize the reconstruction
loss.
So there are, again,
a few more tricks.
Because this is
dealing with language.
And so this is a typical report
from one of these lymphoma
pathologists that says
immunohistochemical stains show
that the follicles-- blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah--
so lots and lots of details.
And so he needed a
representation that
could be put into
this matrix tensor,
this tensor factorization form.
And what he did is to
say, well, let's see.
If we look at a
statement like this,
immuno stains show that
large atypical cells
are strongly positive for
CD30, negative for these other
surface expressions.
So the sentence tells us
relationships among procedures,
types of cells, and
immunologic factors.
And for feature choice,
we can use words.
Or we can use UMLS concepts.
Or we can find various
kinds of mappings.
But he decided that
in order to retain
the syntactic relationships
here, what he would do
is to use a graphical
representation that
came out of, again, parsing
all of these sentences.
And so what you get is that
this creates one graph that
talks about the strongly
positive for CD30,
large atypical cells, et cetera.
And then you can factor
this into subgraphs.
And then you also have
to identify frequently
occurring subgraphs.
So for example,
large atypical cells
appears here, and also appears
there, and of course will
appear in many other places.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this parsing
domain in language diagnostics?
For example, did
they incorporate
some sort of medical
information here
or some sort of linguistic--
PETER SZOLOVITS: So in
this particular study,
he was using the Stanford
Parser with some tricks.
So the Stanford
Parser doesn't know
a lot of the medical words.
And so he basically marked
these things as noun phrases.
And then the
Stanford Parser also
doesn't do well with
long lists like the set
of immune features.
And so he would recognize
those as a pattern,
substitute a single
made-up word for them,
and that made the parser
work much better on it.
So there were a whole
bunch of little tricks
like that in order to adapt it.
But it was not a model
trained specifically on this.
I think it's trained on
Wall Street Journal corpus
or something like that.
So it's general English.
AUDIENCE: Those are things that
he did manually as opposed to,
say, [INAUDIBLE]?
PETER SZOLOVITS: No.
He did it algorithmically,
but he didn't
learn which algorithms to use.
He made them up by hand.
But then, of course,
it's a big corpus.
And he ran these
programs over it
that did those transformations.
So he calls it
two-phase parsing.
There's a reference to his
paper on the first slide
in this section if you're
interested in the details.
It's described there.
So what he wound
up with is a tensor
that has patients on one
axis, the words appearing
in the text on another axis.
So he's still using a
bag-of-words representation.
But the third axis is
these language concept
subgraphs that we
were talking about.
And then he does tensor
factorization on this.
And what's interesting
is that it works
much better than I expected.
So if you look at his technique,
which he called SANTF,
the precision and recall
are about 0.72 and 0.854
macro-average and
0.754 micro-average,
which is much better than
the non-negative matrix
factorization results, which
only use patient by word
or patient by subgraph, or,
in fact, one where you simply
do patient and concatenate
the subgraphs and the words
in one dimension.
So that means that this is
actually taking advantage
of the three-way relationship.
If you read papers from
about 15, 20 years ago,
people got very excited about
the idea of bi-clustering,
which is, in modern terms,
the equivalent of matrix
factorization.
So it says given two
dimensions of data,
and I want to
cluster things, but I
want to cluster
them in such a way
that the clustering
of one dimension
helps the clustering
of the other dimension.
So this is a formal way of doing
that relatively efficiently.
And tensor factorization is
essentially tri-clustering.
So now I'm going to turn to
the last of today's big topics,
which is language modeling.
And this is really where
the action is nowadays
in natural language
processing in general.
I would say that the
natural language processing
on clinical data is
somewhat behind the state
of the art in natural
language processing overall.
There are fewer corpora
that are available.
There are fewer
people working on it.
And so we're catching up.
But I'm going to lead
into this somewhat gently.
So what does it mean
to model a language?
I mean, you could imagine
saying it's coming up
with a set of parsing rules that
define the syntactic structure
of the language.
Or you could imagine
saying, as we suggested
last time, coming up
with a corresponding set
of semantic rules
that say a concept
or terms in the language
correspond to certain concepts
and that they are
a combinatorially,
functionally combined
as the syntax directs,
in order to give us a
semantic representation.
So we don't know how to do
either of those very well.
And so the current,
the contemporary idea
about language
modeling is to say,
given a sequence of tokens,
predict the next token.
If you could do that
perfectly, presumably you
would have a good
language model.
So obviously, you
can't do it perfectly.
Because we don't always
say the same word
after some sequence of
previous words when we speak.
But probabilistically,
you can get close to that.
And there's usually some
kind of Markov assumption
that says that the probability
of emitting a token
given the stuff that came before
it is ordinarily dependent
only on n previous words
rather than on all of history,
on everything you've ever
said before in your life.
And there's a measure
called perplexity,
which is the entropy of the
probability distribution
over the predicted words.
And roughly speaking, it's
the number of likely ways
that you could continue the
text if all of the possibilities
were equally likely.
So perplexity is often used, for
example, in speech processing.
We did a study
where we were trying
to build a speech system that
understood a conversation
between a doctor and a patient.
And we ran into real
problems, because we
were using software that had
been developed to interpret
dictation by doctors.
And that was very well trained.
But it turned out-- we didn't
know this when we started--
that the language that doctors
use in dictating medical notes
is pretty straightforward,
pretty simple.
And so it's perplexity
is about nine,
whereas conversations are much
more free flowing and cover
many more topics.
And so its perplexity
is about 73.
And so the model that works
well for perplexity nine
doesn't work as well
for perplexity 73.
And so what this tells you about
the difficulty of accurately
transcribing speech
is that it's hard.
It's much harder.
And that's still not
a solved problem.
Now, you probably all
know about Zipf's law.
So if you empirically
just take all the words
in all the literature of, let's
say, English, what you discover
is that the n-th word
is about one over n
as probable as the first word.
So there is a
long-tailed distribution.
One thing you should
realize, of course,
is if you integrate one over
n from zero to infinity,
it's infinite.
And that may not be an
inaccurate representation
of language, because language
is productive and changes.
And people make up new words
all the time and so on.
So it may actually be infinite.
But roughly speaking, there is
a kind of decline like this.
And interestingly,
in the brown corpus,
the top 10 words make
up almost a quarter
of the size of the corpus.
So you write a lot of thes,
ofs, ands, a's, twos, ins,
et cetera, and much less
hematemesis, obviously.
So what about n-gram models?
Well, remember, if we make
this Markov assumption,
then all we have to
do is pay attention
to the last n tokens
before the one
that we're interested
in predicting.
And so people have generated
these large corpora n-grams.
So for example, somebody,
a couple of decades ago,
took all of
Shakespeare's writings--
I think they were
trying to decide
whether he had
written all his works
or whether the earl
of somebody or other
was actually the guy
who wrote Shakespeare.
You know about this controversy?
Yeah.
So that's why they
were doing it.
But anyway, they
created this corpus.
And they said--
so Shakespeare had
a vocabulary of about
30,000 words and about
300,000 bigrams, and out of
844 million possible bigrams.
So 99.96% of bigrams
were never seen.
So there's a certain regularity
to his production of language.
Now, Google, of course,
did Shakespeare one better.
And they said, hmm, we can
take a terabyte corpus--
this was in 2006.
I wouldn't be surprised if
it's a petabyte corpus today.
And they published this.
They just made it available.
So there were 13.6
million unique words
that occurred at least 200
times in this tera-word corpus.
And there were 1.2 billion
five-word sequences that
occurred at least 40 times.
So these are the statistics.
And if you're interested,
there's a URL.
And here's a very tiny
part of their database.
So ceramics, collectibles,
collectibles--
I don't know-- occurred 55
times in a terabyte of text.
Ceramics collectibles fine,
ceramics collectibles by,
pottery, cooking, comma, period,
end of sentence, and, at,
is, et cetera--
different number of times.
Ceramics comes from
occurred 660 times,
which is reasonably large
number compared to some
of its competitors here.
If you look at
four-grams, you see
things like serve as the
incoming, blah, blah,
blah, 92 times; serve
as the index, 223 times;
serve as the
initial, 5,300 times.
So you've got all
these statistics.
And now, given those statistics,
we can then build a generator.
So we can say, all right.
Suppose I start with
the token, which
is the beginning of a
sentence, or the separator
between sentences.
And I say sample a
random bigram starting
with the beginning of
a sentence and a word,
according to its probability,
and then sample the next bigram
from that word and
all the other words,
according to its
probability, and keep
doing that until you hit
the end of sentence marker.
So for example, here I'm
generating the sentence,
I, starts with I,
then followed by want,
followed by two, followed
by get, followed by Chinese,
followed by food, followed
by end of sentence.
So I've just generated,
"I want to get
Chinese food," which sounds
like a perfectly good sentence.
So here's what's interesting.
If you look back again
at the Shakespeare corpus
and saying, if we generated
Shakespeare from unigrams,
you get stuff like
at the top, "To him
swallowed confess here both.
Which.
Of save on trail for are ay
device and rote life have."
It doesn't sound terribly good.
It's not very grammatical.
It doesn't have that sort of
Shakespearean English flavor.
Although, you do have words
like nave and ay and so on that
are vaguely reminiscent.
Now, if you go to
bigrams, it starts
to sound a little better.
"What means, sir.
I confess she?
Then all sorts, he
is trim, captain."
That doesn't make any sense.
But it starts to
sound a little better.
And with trigrams, we get,
"Sweet prince, Falstaff
shall die.
Harry of Monmouth," et cetera.
So this is beginning to
sound a little Shakespearean.
And if you go to quadrigrams,
you get, "King Henry.
What?
I will go seek the
traitor Gloucester.
Exeunt some of the watch.
A great banquet
serv'd in," et cetera.
I mean, when I first saw this,
like 20 years ago or something,
I was stunned.
This is actually
generating stuff
that sounds vaguely
Shakespearean and vaguely
English-like.
Here's an example of generating
the Wall Street Journal.
So from unigrams, "Months
the my and issue of year
foreign new exchanges
September were recession."
It's word salad.
But if you go to trigrams,
"They also point to ninety nine
point six billion
from two hundred four
oh six three percent of the
rates of interest stores
as Mexico and Brazil."
So you could imagine that this
is some Wall Street Journal
writer on acid
writing this text.
Because it has a little bit
of the right kind of flavor.
So more recently,
people said, well,
we ought to be able to make use
of this in some systematic way
to help us with our
language analysis tasks.
So to me, the first
effort in this direction
was Word2Vec, which
was Mikolov's approach
to doing this.
And he developed two models.
He said, let's build a
continuous bag-of-words model
that says what
we're going to use
is co-occurrence data on a
series of tokens in the text
that we're trying to model.
And we're going to
use a neural network
model to predict the word
from the words around it.
And in that process,
we're going to use
the parameters of that neural
network model as a vector.
And that vector will be the
representation of that word.
And so what we're
going to find is
that words that tend to
appear in the same context
will have similar
representations
in this high-dimensional vector.
And by the way,
high-dimensional,
people typically use like 300
or 500 dimensional vectors.
So there's a lot of--
it's a big space.
And the words are
scattered throughout this.
But you get this
kind of cohesion,
where words that are
used in the same context
appear close to each other.
And the extrapolation
of that is that if words
are used in the
same context, maybe
they share something
about meaning.
So the other model
is a skip-gram model,
where you're doing
the prediction
in the other direction.
From a word, you're predicting
the words that are around it.
And again, you are using
a neural network model
to do that.
And you use the
parameters of that model
in order to represent the
word that you're focused on.
So what came as a surprise
to me is this claim that's
in his original paper, which
is that not only do you
get this effect of locality
as corresponding meaning
but that you get relationships
that are geometrically
represented in the space
of these embeddings.
And so what you
see is that if you
take the encoding of the
word man and the word woman
and look at the vector
difference between them,
and then apply that same
vector difference to king,
you get close to queen.
And if you apply it uncle,
you get close to aunt.
And so they showed a
number of examples.
And then people
have studied this.
It doesn't hold
it perfectly well.
I mean, it's not like we've
solved the semantics problem.
But it is a genuine
relationship.
The place where it
doesn't work well
is when some of these things are
much more frequent than others.
And so one of the examples
that's often cited
is if you go, London is to
England as Paris is to France,
and that one works.
But then you say as Kuala
Lumpur is to Malaysia,
and that one doesn't
work so well.
And then you go, as
Juba or something
is to whatever country
it's the capital of.
And since we don't write about
Africa in our newspapers,
there's very little
data on that.
And so that doesn't
work so well.
So there was this
other paper later
from van der Maaten
and Geoff Hinton,
where they came up with
a visualization method
to take these
high-dimensional vectors
and visualize them
in two dimensions.
And what you see is that if
you take a bunch of concepts
that are count concepts--
so 1/2, 30, 15, 5, 4, 2,
3, several, some, many,
et cetera--
there is a geometric
relationship between them.
So they, in fact, do map to
the same part of the space.
Similarly, minister, leader,
president, chairman, director,
spokesman, chief,
head, et cetera
form a kind of
cluster in the space.
So there's definitely
something to this.
I promised you that I would
get back to a different attempt
to try to take a
core of concepts
that you want to use
for term-spotting
and develop an automated way of
enlarging that set of concepts
in order to give you a
richer vocabulary by which
to try to identify cases
that you're interested in.
So this was by some
of my colleagues,
including Kat, who
you saw on Tuesday.
And they said,
well, what we'd like
is the fully automated and
robust, unsupervised feature
selection method that
leverages only publicly
available medical knowledge
sources instead of VHR data.
So the method that David's
group had developed,
which we talked about
earlier, uses data
from electronic
health records, which
means that you move
to different hospitals
and there may be
different conventions.
And you might
imagine that you have
to retrain that sort of method,
whereas here the idea is
to derive these surrogate
features from knowledge
sources.
So unlike that earlier model,
here they built a Word2Vec
skip-gram model from about 5
million Springer articles--
so these are published
medical articles--
to yield 500 dimensional
vectors for each word.
And then what they did is
they took the concept names
that they were interested
in and their definitions
from the UMLS, and
then they summoned
the word vectors for each
of these words, weighted
by inverse document frequency.
So it's sort of a
TF-IDF-like approach
to weight different words.
And then they went
out and they said, OK,
for every disease that's
mentioned in Wikipedia,
Medscape, eMedicine, the
Merck Manuals Professional
Edition, the Mayo Clinic
Diseases and Conditions,
MedlinePlus Medical
Encyclopedia,
they used named entity
recognition techniques
to find all the concepts that
are related to this phenotype.
So then they said, well,
there's a lot of randomness
in these sources, and maybe
in our extraction techniques.
But if we insist that
some concept appear
in at least three of
these five sources,
then we can be pretty confident
that it's a relevant concept.
And so they said,
OK, we'll do that.
Then they chose
the top k concepts
whose embedding vectors are
closest by cosine distance
to the embedding
of this phenotype
that they've calculated.
And they say, OK,
the phenotype is
going to be a linear combination
of all these related concepts.
So again, this is a bit
similar to what we saw before.
But here, instead of
extracting the data
from electronic medical
records, they're
extracting it from published
literature and these web
sources.
And again, what you see is that
the expert-curated features
for these five phenotypes,
which are coronary artery
disease, rheumatoid
arthritis, Crohn's
disease, ulcerative colitis,
and pediatric pulmonary arterial
hypertension, they started
with 20 to 50 curated features.
So these were the
ones that the doctors
said, OK, these are the
anchors in David's terminology.
And then they expanded
these to a larger set
using the technique that I just
described, and then selected
down to the top n that
were effective in finding
relevant phenotypes.
And this is a terrible graph
that summarizes the results.
But what you're seeing is that
the orange lines are based
on the expert-curated features.
This is based on an earlier
version of trying to do this.
And SEDFE is the technique
that I've just described.
And what you see is that
the automatic techniques
for many of these phenotypes
are just about as good
as the manually curated ones.
And of course, they require
much less manual curation.
Because they're using this
automatic learning approach.
Another interesting
example to return
to the theme of
de-identification
is a couple of my
students, a few years ago,
built a new de-identifier
that has this rather
complicated architecture.
So it starts with a
bi-directional recursive neural
network model that
is implemented
over the character sequences
of words in the medical text.
So why character sequences?
Why might those be important?
Well, consider a misspelled
word, for example.
Most of the character
sequence is correct.
There will be a bug in
it at the misspelling.
Or consider that a
lot of medical terms
are these compound
terms, where they're
made up of lots of
pieces that correspond
to Greek or Latin roots.
So learning those can
actually be very helpful.
So you start with that model.
You then could
concatenate the results
from both the left-running and
the right-running recursive
neural network.
And concatenate that with
the Word2Vec embedding
of the whole word.
And you feed that into another
bi-directional RNN layer.
And then for each word, you
take the output of those RNNs,
run them through a feed-forward
neural network in order
to estimate the prob--
it's like a soft max.
And you estimate the probability
of this word belonging
to a particular category of
personally identifiable health
information.
So is it a name?
Is it an address?
Is it a phone number?
Is it or whatever?
And then the top layer is a
kind of conditional random
field-like layer that imposes
a sequential probability
distribution that says, OK,
if you've seen a name, then
what's the next most likely
thing that you're going to see?
And so you combine that with
the probability distributions
for each word in order to
identify the category of PHI
or non-PHI for that word.
And this did insanely well.
So optimized by F1 score, we're
up at a precision of 99.2%,
recall of 99.3%.
Optimized by recall,
we're up at about 98%, 99%
for each of them.
So this is doing quite well.
Now, there is a non-machine
learning comment to make,
which is that if you read
the HIPAA law, the HIPAA
regulations, they
don't say that you
must get rid of 99%
of the personally
identifying information in
order to be able to share
this data for research.
It says you have to
get rid of all of it.
So no technique we
know is 100% perfect.
And so there's a kind of
practical understanding
among people who
work on this stuff
that nothing's
going to be perfect.
And therefore, that you can
get away with a little bit.
But legally, you're on thin ice.
So I remember many years ago,
my wife was in law school.
And I asked her at one point,
so what can people sue you for?
And she said,
absolutely anything.
They may not win.
But they can be a
real pain if you have
to go defend yourself in court.
And so this hasn't
played out yet.
We don't know if a
de-identifier that
is 99% sensitive
and 99% specific
will pass muster with people
who agree to release data sets.
Because they're worried,
too, about winding up
in the newspaper or
winding up getting sued.
Last topic for today--
so if you read this interesting
blog, which, by the way,
has a very good
tutorial on BERT,
he says, "The year 2018 has been
an inflection point for machine
learning models handling
text, or more accurately, NLP.
Our conceptual
understanding of how
best to represent words
and sentences in a way
that best captures underlying
meanings and relationships
is rapidly evolving."
And so there are a
whole bunch of new ideas
that have come about in about
the last year or two years,
including ELMo, which learns
context-specific embeddings,
the Transformer architecture,
this BERT approach.
And then I'll end with just
showing you this gigantic GPT
model that was developed
by the OpenAI people, which
does remarkably better
than the stuff I showed you
before in generating language.
All right.
If you look inside
Google Translate,
at least as of not
long ago, what you find
is a model like this.
So it's essentially an LSTM
model that takes input words
and munges them together
into some representation,
a high-dimensional vector
representation, that summarizes
everything that the model
knows about that sentence
that you've just fed it.
Obviously, it has to be
a pretty high-dimensional
representation, because your
sentence could be about almost
anything.
And so it's important to
be able to capture all
that in this representation.
But basically, at
this point, you
start generating the output.
So if you're translating
English to French,
these are English
words coming in,
and these are French words
going out, in sort of the way
I showed you, where we're
generating Shakespeare
or we're generating Wall
Street Journal text.
But the critical feature here
is that in the initial version
of this, everything
that you learned
about this English sentence
had to be encoded in this one
vector that got passed from
the encoder into the decoder,
or from the source language into
the target language generator.
So then someone came
along and said, hmm--
someone, namely these
guys, came along and said,
wouldn't it be nice
if we could provide
some auxiliary information
to the generator that said,
hey, which part of
the input sentence
should you pay attention to?
And of course, there's
no fixed answer to that.
I mean, if I'm translating
an arbitrary English sentence
into an arbitrary French
sentence, I can't say,
in general, look at the third
word in the English sentence
when you're generating the third
word in the French sentence.
Because that may or may
not be true, depending
on the particular sentence.
But on the other
hand, the intuition
is that there is such
a positional dependence
and a dependence on what the
particular English word was
that is an important component
of generating the French word.
And so they created this
idea that in addition
to passing along
the this vector that
encodes the meaning
of the entire input
and the previous word that you
had generated in the output,
in addition, we pass along this
other information that says,
which of the input words
should we pay attention to?
And how much attention
should we pay to them?
And of course, in the
style of these embeddings,
these are all represented
by high-dimensional vectors,
high-dimensional real
number vectors that
get combined with
the other vectors
in order to produce the output.
Now, a classical linguist
would look at this and retch.
Because this looks nothing
like classical linguistics.
It's just numerology that gets
trained by stochastic gradient
descent methods in order
to optimize the output.
But from an engineering point
of view, it works quite well.
So then for a while, that
was the state of the art.
And then last year, these
guys, Vaswani et al.
came along and said,
you know, we now
have this complicated
architecture,
where we are doing the
old-style translation where
we summarize everything
into one vector,
and then use that to generate
a sequence of outputs.
And we have this
attention mechanism
that tells us how
much of various inputs
to use in generating each
element of the output.
Is the first of those
actually necessary?
And so they published this
lovely paper saying attention
is all you need,
that says, hey, you
know that thing that you guys
have added to this translation
model.
Not only is it a
useful addition,
but in fact, it can take the
place of the original model.
And so the Transformer
is an architecture that
is the hottest thing
since sliced bread
at the moment, that says,
OK, here's what we do.
We take the inputs.
We calculate some
embedding for them.
We then want to
retain the position,
because of course, the sequence
in which the words appear,
it matters.
And the positional encoding
is this weird thing
where it encodes using
sine waves so that--
it's an orthogonal basis.
And so it has nice
characteristics.
And then we run it
into an attention model
that is essentially
computing self-attention.
So it's saying what--
it's like Word2Vec, except
in a more sophisticated way.
So it's looking at all
the words in the sentence
and saying, which words is
this word most related to?
And then, in order to
complicate it some more,
they say, well, we don't
want just a single notion
of attention.
We want multiple
notions of attention.
So what does that sound like?
Well, to me, it
sounds a bit like what
you see in convolutional
neural networks,
where often when you're
processing an image with a CNN,
you're not only applying
one filter to the image
but you're applying a whole
bunch of different filters.
And because you
initialize them randomly,
you hope that they
will converge to things
that actually detect different
interesting properties
of the image.
So the same idea here--
that what they're
doing is they're
starting with a bunch of these
attention matrices and saying,
we initialize them randomly.
They will evolve
into something that
is most useful for helping us
deal with the overall problem.
So then they run
this through a series
of, I think, in Vaswani's paper,
something like six layers that
are just replicated.
And there are additional things
like feeding forward the input
signal in order to add it to
the output signal of the stage,
and then normalizing,
and then rerunning it,
and then running it through
a feed-forward network that
also has a bypass that combines
the input with the output
of the feed-forward network.
And then you do this
six times, or n times.
And that then feeds
into the generator.
And the generator then uses
a very similar architecture
to calculate output
probabilities,
And then it samples from those
in order to generate the text.
So this is sort of
the contemporary way
that one can do translation,
using this approach.
Obviously, I don't have time to
go into all the details of how
all this is done.
And I'd probably
do it wrong anyway.
But you can look at the paper,
which gives a good explanation.
And that blog that I
pointed to also has
a pointer to another
blog post by the same guy
that does a pretty good job
of explaining the Transformer
architecture.
It's complicated.
So what you get out of the
multi-head attention mechanism
is that--
here is one attention machine.
And for example, the colors
here indicate the degree
to which the encoding
of the word "it"
depends on the other
words in the sentence.
And you see that it's focused on
the animal, which makes sense.
Because "it," in
fact, is referring
to the animal in this sentence.
Here they introduce
another encoding.
And this one focuses on "was
too tired," which is also good.
Because "it," again, refers to
the thing that was too tired.
And of course, by
multi-headed, they
mean that it's doing
this many times.
And so you're
identifying all kinds
of different relationships
in the input sentence.
Well, along the same lines
is this encoding called ELMo.
People seem to like
Sesame Street characters.
So ELMo is based on a
bi-directional LSTM.
So it's an older technology.
But what it does
is, unlike Word2Vec,
which built an embedding
for each type--
so every time the
word "junk" appears,
it gets the same embedding.
Here what they're saying is,
hey, take context seriously.
And we're going to calculate
a different embedding
for each occurrence
in context of a token.
And this turns out
to be very good.
Because it goes part
of the way to solving
the word-sense
disambiguation problem.
So this is just an example.
If you look at the word
"play" in GloVe, which
is a slightly more
sophisticated variant
of the Word2Vec approach,
you get playing, game, games,
played, players, plays, player,
play, football, multiplayer.
This all seems to
be about games.
Because probably,
from the literature
that they got this from,
that's the most common usage
of the word "play."
Whereas, using this
bi-directional language model,
they can separate
out something like,
"Kieffer, the only
junior in the group,
was commended for his ability
to hit in the clutch, as well as
his all-around excellent play."
So this is presumably
the baseball player.
And here is, "They
were actors who
had been handed fat roles
in a successful play."
So this is a different
meaning of the word play.
And so this embedding also
has made really important
contributions to improving the
quality of natural language
processing by being able
to deal with the fact
that single words have multiple
meanings not only in English
but in other languages.
So after ELMo comes BERT, which
is this Bidirectional Encoder
Representations
from Transformers.
So rather than using the LSTM
kind of model that ELMo used,
these guys say, well,
let's hop on the bandwagon,
use the Transformer-based
architecture.
And then they introduced
some interesting tricks.
So one of the problems
with Transformers
is if you stack them on
top of each other there
are many paths from
any of the inputs
to any of the intermediate
nodes and the outputs.
And so if you're
doing self-attention,
you're trying to figure
out where the output should
pay attention to the input,
the answer, of course,
is like, if you're trying
to reconstruct the input,
if the input is present in
your model, what you will learn
is that the
corresponding word is
the right word for your output.
So they have to prevent
that from happening.
And so the way they do
it is by masking off,
at each level, some fraction
of the words or of the inputs
at that level.
So what this is doing
is it's a little bit
like the skip-gram model
in Word2Vec, where it's
trying to predict the
likelihood of some word,
except it doesn't know
what a significant fraction
of the words are.
And so it can't overfit in the
way that I was just suggesting.
So this turned out
to be a good idea.
It's more complicated.
Again, for the details,
you have to read the paper.
I gave both the Transformer
paper and the BERT paper
as optional readings for today.
I meant to give them
as required readings,
but I didn't do it in time.
So they're optional.
But there are a whole
bunch of other tricks.
So instead of using words,
they actually used word pieces.
So think about syllables and
don't becomes do and apostrophe
t, and so on.
And then they discovered
that about 15% of the tokens
to be masked seems to work
better than other percentages.
So those are the hidden tokens
that prevent overfitting.
And then they do some
other weird stuff.
Like, instead of
masking a token,
they will inject random other
words from the vocabulary
into its place, again,
to prevent overfitting.
And then they look at
different tasks like,
can I predict the next
sentence in a corpus?
So I read a sentence.
And the translation is
not into another language.
But it's predicting what the
next sentence is going to be.
So they trained it on 800
million words from something
called the Books corpus
and about 2 and 1/2
million-word Wikipedia corpus.
And what they found
was that there
is an enormous improvement
on a lot of classical tasks.
So this is a listing of
some of the standard tasks
for natural language processing,
mostly not in the medical world
but in the general NLP domain.
And you see that you get things
like an improvement from 80%.
Or even the GPT model
that I'll talk about
in a minute is at 82%.
They're up to about 86%.
So a 4% improvement in
this domain is really huge.
I mean, very often
people publish papers
showing a 1% improvement.
And if their corpus
is big enough,
then it's statistically
significant,
and therefore publishable.
But it's not significant in the
ordinary meaning of the term
significant, if you're
doing 1% better.
But doing 4% better
is pretty good.
Here we're going
from like 66% to 72%
from the earlier
state of the art--
82 to 91; 93 to 94; 35 to
60 in the CoLA task corpus
of linguistic acceptability.
So this is asking, I
think, Mechanical Turk
people, for generated
sentences, is this sentence
a valid sentence of English?
And so it's an
interesting benchmark.
So it's producing really
significant improvements
all over the place.
They trained two models of it.
The base model is
the smaller one.
The large model is just
trained on larger data sets.
Enormous amount of computation
in doing this training--
so I've forgotten, it
took them like a month
on some gigantic
cluster of GPU machines.
And so it's daunting,
because you can't just
crank this up on your
laptop and expect
it to finish in your lifetime.
The last thing I want to
tell you about is this GPT-2.
So this is from the
OpenAI Institute,
which is one of these
philanthropically funded--
I think, this one,
by Elon Musk--
research institute
to advance AI.
And what they said is, well,
this is all cool, but--
so they were not using BERT.
They were using the
Transformer architecture
but without the same
training style as BERT.
And they said, the
secret is going
to be that we're going to apply
this not only to one problem
but to a whole
bunch of problems.
So it's a multi-task
learning approach that says,
we're going to
build a better model
by trying to solve a bunch of
different tasks simultaneously.
And so they built
enormous models.
By the way, the task itself is
given as a sequence of tokens.
So for example, they
might have a task
that says translate to French,
English text, French text.
Or answer the question,
document, question, answer.
And so the system
not only learns
how to do whatever
it's supposed to do.
But it even learns
something about the tasks
that it's being asked to work
on by encoding these and using
them as part of its model.
So they built four
different models.
Take a look at the bottom one.
1.5 billion parameters--
this is a large model.
This is a very large model.
And so it's a byte-level model.
So they just said forget
words, because we're trying
to do this multilingually.
And so for Chinese,
you want characters.
And for English, you might
as well take characters also.
And the system will, in
its 1.5 billion parameters,
learn all about the sequences of
characters that make up words.
And it'll be cool.
And so then they look at a whole
bunch of different challenges.
And what you see is that the
state of the art before they
did this on, for example,
the Lambada data set
was that the perplexity of
its predictions was a hundred.
And with this large model, the
perplexity of its predictions
is about nine.
So that means that it's
reduced the uncertainty of what
to predict next
ridiculously much--
I mean, by more than
an order of magnitude.
And you get similar
gains, accuracy going
from 59% to 63% accuracy on a--
this is the children's
something-or-other challenge--
from 85% to 93%--
so dramatic improvements
almost across the board,
except for this
particular data set,
where they did not do well.
And what really blew
me away is here's
an application of this
1.5 billion-word model
that they built. So they
said, OK, I give you a prompt,
like the opening paragraph
of a Wall Street Journal
article or a Wikipedia article.
And you complete the article
by using that generator idea
that I showed you before, that
just uses the language model
and picks the most
likely word to come next
and emits that as the next word.
So here is a prompt that says,
"A train carriage containing
controlled nuclear materials
was stolen in Cincinnati today.
Its whereabouts are unknown."
By the way, this is made up.
I mean, this is not
a real news article.
And the system comes
back with a completion
that says, "The incident
occurred on the downtown train
line, which runs from
Covington and Ashland stations.
In an email to
Ohio news outlets,
the US Department
of Energy said it's
working with the Federal
Railroad Administration
to find the thief," et cetera.
This looks astoundingly good.
Now, the paper from
which this comes--
this is actually from a
blog, but they've also
published a paper about it--
claims that these examples
are not even cherry-picked.
If you go to that page and
pick sample 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, et cetera, you get
different examples
that they claim are
not cherry-picked.
And every one of
them is really good.
I mean, you could imagine
this being an actual article
about this actual event.
So somehow or other,
in this enormous model,
and with this
Transformer technology,
and with the multi-task
training that they've done,
they have managed
to capture so much
of the regularity of
the English language
that they can generate these
fake news articles based
on a prompt and make them
look unbelievably realistic.
Now, interestingly,
they have chosen not
to release that trained model.
Because they're worried that
people will, in fact, do this,
and that they will generate
fake news articles all the time.
They've released a
much smaller model
that is not nearly as good
in terms of its realism.
So that's the state of the
art in language modeling
at the moment.
And as I say, the general domain
is ahead of the medical domain.
But you can bet
that there are tons
of people who are sitting
around looking at exactly
these results and
saying, well, we
ought to be able to
take advantage of this
to build much better language
models for the medical domain
and to exploit them in order
to do phenotyping, in order
to do entity recognition,
in order to do inference,
in order to do
question answering,
in order to do any of
these kinds of topics.
And I was talking to
Patrick Winston, who
is one of the good
old-fashioned AI people,
as he characterizes himself.
And the thing that's a
little troublesome about this
is that this technology
has virtually nothing
to do with anything
that we understand
about language or about
inference or about question
answering or about anything.
And so one is left with
this queasy feeling that,
here is a wonderful engineering
solution to a whole set
of problems, but
it's unclear how
it relates to the original goal
of artificial intelligence,
which is to understand something
about human intelligence
by simulating it in a computer.
Maybe our BCS
friends will discover
that there are, in fact,
transformer mechanisms deeply
buried in our brain.
But I would be surprised
if that turned out
to be exactly the case.
But perhaps there is
something like that going on.
And so this leaves an
interesting scientific
conundrum of,
exactly what have we
learned from this type of very,
very successful model building?
OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]